ariane vous allez reprendre la parole
mais avant de vous passer le micro à
rien juste pour vous dire ami
entrepreneur chef d'entreprise qui vous
êtes connecté je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez poser vos questions dès
maintenant à jean marc jancovici
il répondra aussi au président national
du cjd et puis avant d'y aller mollo
marraine donc n'hésitez pas à me poser
toutes les questions en prenant le
maximum ariane tout à fait ça est ce que
je propose c'est de présenter très
rapidement jean-marc avant lui donner la
parole merci jean marc d'être là parmi
nous aujourd'hui nous avons le privilège
de vous accueillir et c'est un grand
honneur car vous êtes en experts de
premier plan sur les sujets énergie
climat que vous explorez depuis plus de
20 ans avec la rigueur scientifique qui
vous caractérisent
vous êtes ingénieur enseignants à mines
paristech et j'en profite pour indiquer
que tous vos cours sont disponibles sur
internet et qu'elles sont aussi
accessibles que passionnant vous êtes
associé fondateur du cabinet carbone 4
fondateur et président de the shift
project un think tank qui oeuvre à la
décarbonation de l'économie vous êtes
membre du haut conseil du climat et
enfin auteur et conférencier vous
répéter qu avant d'agir il est
indispensable de bien comprendre le
problème
alors jean marc nous vous laissons
l'exposer aux professionnels qui nous
écoutent
avant de nous retrouver dans une demi
heure pour une séance de
questions-réponses
1ère 1 vous m'entendez oui très bien
vous entends ça que ce simple alors
qu'avant j'ai une très bonne nouvelle
pour vous heureusement que je ne suis
pas venu car j'ai appris plus tard que
hier soir que j'étais qu'un compact pour
le co lead donc vous avez tous échappé à
une mort douloureuse longue grâce à mon
absence
voilà j'espère que vous m'en serais
évidemment reconnaissant la deuxième
chose que je vais faire c'est que donc
si j'ai bien compris on avait décidé de
découper cette séquence en deux morceaux
il ya un premier morceau où je vais
essayer de vous raconter un tout petit
peu ce que j'ai moi-même compris quelque
part sur le problème à traiter quand on
parle du problème énergie climat
et puis derrière il y aura une séquence
de questions donc je vais prendre une
grosse demi heure au début pour faire un
tout petit résumé du cours dans marianne
vient de parler et ensuite on aura
j'aurai le plaisir d'échanger avec vous
pour voir des fois que ça vous suggère
une petite grattage de tête
vous voyez le partage d'écran en live à
la con que ça vient ici est parti c'est
bon oui alors le seul parti donc je vais
vous raconter quelques petites choses
sur le changement climatique qui en ce
moment comme vous le savez occulte
parfois de temps en temps quand on ne
s'occupe pas du bolide
vous avez peut-être en tête qu'il ya
quelques années maintenant s'est tenu à
paris
une édition des négociations qui naquit
à une fois par an en contient pas de
candidat et que en 2015
on a transformé monsieur fabius en
commissaire-priseur et nous avons
déclaré adopter un accord dit l'accord
de paris qui dans l'esprit de tout le
monde est le début du chemin vers une
résolution du problème
alors vous allez voir que
malheureusement les choses ne sont pas
aussi simple que ça et que le problème
il est un peu plus compliquée que
quelque chose qu'ils demanderaient juste
un peu de bonne volonté au niveau des
états pour être je vais commencer par
rappeler une chose c'est que le problème
auquel nous avons affaire actuellement
quand on parle de changement climatique
est un problème d'ordre de grandeur et
de vitesse d'évolution et non pas un
problème de nouveautés total des
phénomènes le changement climatique ça
fait quelques milliards d'années que la
terre avait l'atmosphère
ça fait donc quelques milliards d'années
que la terre un système climatique du
reste vous avez un système climatique
pas du tout le même sur vénus vous avez
un système climatique sur mars
vous avez un système climatique sur
jupiter vous avez un système climatique
dès lors que vous avez une planète avec
une atmosphère au dessus ce système
climatique il est susceptible de varier
à cause de tout un tas de facteurs je
pars dans le temps d'entrer dans le
détail de ceux qui sont évoqués ici
juste ça peut varier parce que la
puissance du solaire varie parce que les
la forme de leur vie terrestre varie
parce que les continents dérive parce
que c est ça varie à des échelles de
temps que vous voyez ici qui vont de
n'importe quoi entre quelques jours voir
un peu plus et des milliards d'années
alors là en fait c'est juste des
centaines de millions d'années c'est
gratuit en année et les causes de cette
variation dépendent évidemment un pardon
s'applique à des échelles de temps qui
dépendent par exemple pour que la dérive
des continents change de climat il faut
attendre de l'ordre du million d'années
où la dizaine de millions d'années par
contre pour attendre que quelque chose
qui se passe avec les calottes
glaciaires chambles climat là il suffit
d'attendre quelques milliers ou dizaines
de milliers d'années on va dire plutôt
de leurs données
de milliers d'années et pour attendre
que quelque chose qui se passe dans
l'atmosphère change les conditions au
sol et voilà c'est plutôt quelque chose
vous renvoyer en quelques jours vous
pouvez avoir du soleil de la pluie un
peu plus chaud donc le climat varie à
d'état des chefs de temps et à l'échelle
de la semaine la variation du système
elle est purement atmosphérique vous
voyez dans la barre qui est à l'échelle
de la semaine eh bien ça de couple une
seule qu'un seul truc là qui s'appelle
atmosphère donc un bon modèle météo
c'est un bon modèle atmosphérique ça
suffit on n'a pas besoin de s'occuper du
reste et c'est vraiment ça qui prime
à cg chef de temps quand on parle de
réchauffement climatique
on parle souvent à l'échelle du siècle
voire au delà et à ce moment ce que vous
voyez c'est qu'à l'échelle du siècle en
fait la variabilité atmosphérique
elle joue plus tellement ce qui va jouer
à l'échelle du siècle c'est
essentiellement la variabilité océanique
et donc le volcanisme et le sol
si vous aller encore plus loin dans le
temps vous avez encore d'autres
paramètres et notamment les variations
de l'orbité terrestre qui se met à être
des éléments importants donc le
changement climatique a toujours existé
sauf qu'il a toujours existé à des
échelles de temps qui n'était pas
nécessairement celle qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui
en fait la question qui est aujourd'hui
posée à la communauté scientifique et
qui concernent directement l'humanité
c est ce que l'homme la femme les êtres
humains sont devenus la première cause
de variation du système à l'échelle du
siècle
donc la première cause à l'échelle du
siècle et si oui où est ce que ça peut
nous emmener
c'est bien ça la question qui est posée
aujourd'hui à la communauté scientifique
alors la cause de variation du système à
l'échelle du siècle la fois ci ça
s'appelle les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre à gaz à effet de serre ça une
définition assez simple en physique
c'est un gaz qui est opaque aux
infrarouges émis par la surface de la
planète la surface de la planète aimé du
rayonnement qui ressemble à de la
lumière mais juste avec des longueurs
d'onde un peu plus grande qui s'appelle
du rayonnement infrarouge votre corps en
avait aussi c'est grâce à ça qu'on est
capable de le voir avec des caméras
infrarouges caméra normale voit le petit
dernier est en train de jouer sur la
plage dans le rayonnement visible et une
caméra infrarouge
même chose mais la nuit grâce au
rayonnement infrarouge émis par notre
corps est bien apte à la surface de la
planète qui est une température pas très
éloignée de celle de notre corps et
biens aimés des infrarouges et c'est
infrarouge quand ils repartent vers
l'espace s'ils rencontrent sur leur
chemin un gaz qui s'appelle un gaz à
effet de serre ils sont arrêtés en
chemin et à ce moment l'énergie du
rayonnement infrarouge est conservé au
niveau où elle a été arrêtée
donc plus vous rajoutez de gaz qui
absorbe les infrarouges dans
l'atmosphère est plus l'énergie émise
par la surface de la planète sous forme
de rayonnement infrarouge et d'arrêter
près du sol et donc contribuer à
réchauffer le sol en bourse si ça s'est
un peu sympa ce que je viens de vous
expliquer vers en gros c'est l'idée
alors l'homme pardon les gaz à effet de
serre présents dans l'atmosphère
les deux principaux c'est la vapeur
d'eau et gaz carbonique ça fait des
milliards d'années qui sont là donc
c'est très très vieux le prénom de gaz
carbonique
mais l'homme actuellement est en train
d'en rajouter en plus des sources
naturelles et ce rajout vous le voyez
ici exprimé en millions de tonnes de co2
équivalent donc là dix millions dix
millions dix milliards de tonnes
et maintenant on est à peu près à 60
milliards de tonnes de co2 équivalent
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre le
principal d'entre eux c'est de co2 que
vous voyez ici les émissions humaines de
vapeur d'eau sont négligeables dans le
cycle naturel de l'eau donc on les
compte pas et puis vous avez d'autres
garages on peut parler moins souvent le
méthane très associé à l'élevage très
associée aux rizières et un peu à
l'exploitation des hydrocarbures est ici
vous avez le protoxyde d'azoté très
associé à d'agriculture et les fuites de
fluides frigorigènes des gaz halogénés
qui sont associés essentiellement aux
chaînes de froid
ce que vous voyez sur ce graphique c'est
que depuis un siècle et demi ces
émissions augmentent et augmente et
augmente et il n'y a pas grand chose qui
les empêchent d'augmenter et en
particulier aucun progrès technique
jusqu'à maintenant ne les a empêché
d'augmenter
on dit souvent par exemple que
l'électrification des usagers quelque
chose qui fera baisser les émissions bas
historiquement sap a été vrai
l'électricité s'est beaucoup développé
les émissions aussi on dit par exemple
que la digitalisation permettra d
des émissions ça rendra les choses
efficacement vous voyez des ordinateurs
sa date maintenant de plus d'un demi
siècle a fait ça n'a pas vraiment fait
baisser les émissions planétaires
on dit que le ferroviaire permet de
faire baisser les émissions parce que le
train trajet en train d'être
efficacement le voyage de quand datent
de les trains à grande vitesse sont les
travées train tout pour ses troubles y
tient et vous oubliez ça n'a pas
vraiment fait baisser les émissions en
voilà un goût de digital et enfin le
dernier la dernière chose en date c'est
qu'on dit que les nouvelles énergies
renouvelables dont le solaire et
l'éolien
ça permet de faire baisser les émissions
vous voyez de quoi on sert date le début
de la 2 du déploiement de des éoliennes
et des panneaux solaires et pour le
moment ça permet pas vraiment de faire
baisser les émissions
donc ce que je suis en train de vous
montrer là c'est qu'on moment il ya une
espèce de hausse qui avaient un exo
râble alors en fait ne sera pas des
émissions est à peu près aucune
innovation technique quand on les
replace sur cette courbe n'a été de
nature à infléchir la trajectoire en ce
qui concerne les émissions planétaires
parce qu'il a il s'agit bien des
émissions planétaires de gaz à effet de
serre ce qui veut dire que une des
choses qu'il faut se demander c'est à
chaque fois qu'on se dit tiens c'est un
train de baisser ici ça n'est pas
abattre oui il savait si si mais est-ce
que la contrepartie c'est pas que c'est
en train d'augmenter la alors une
mauvaise nouvelle avec et c'est bien
pour ça qu'on a un problème avec le
premier des gaz à effet de serre qu'on
met dans l'atmosphère c'est que une fois
qu'on lit mais il a strictement aucune
envie de sanary le co2 dioxyde de
carbone est un d'occident le
dictionnaire est bien fait et il se
trouve que les oxydes sont sur terre
pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont des vieux
souvenirs de chimie matière horrible qui
nous torture est sur les bancs de
l'école
vous vous rappellerez peut-être que les
oxydes son défend très stable dans les
composés chimiques sur terre c'est à
dire qu'une fois qu'un corps a été oxydé
il a strictement aucune envie de changer
d'état c'est un mariage entendu que
tristan et iseult l'occident c'est
quelque chose qui dure éternellement ou
presque éternellement il ya un oxyde que
vous utilisez tous les jours du soir au
matin et du matin ou soir que vous
connaissez très bien qui l oxyde de
dihydrogène
pioneer non plus pour en vous connaissez
bien ces lots lot c'est un toxines
d'hydrogène et ça fait des milliards
d'années que sur terre c'est présent
sous forme d'eau ça se dissocie pas pour
faire autre chose et le faire par
exemple le minerai de fer aujourd'hui
est disponible sur un dock side parce
que depuis qu'il ya de l'oxygène dans
l'air et de centaines de millions
d'années tout le fer disponibles sur
terre c'est oxydé et maintenant vous ne
trouvez pas de faire autrement enfin
exception vous le trouvez pas autrement
que souvent d'oxydé une fois qu'il est
souvent d'occitan il reste comme ça des
dizaines des centaines de millions
d'années ça lui va très bien
eh bien le co2 c'est exactement pareil
tant qu'il est dans l'air il est éternel
c'est à dire qu'il n'a pas de processus
d'épuration du co2 tant qu'il est dans
l'atmosphère au milieu de l'atmosphère
pour que le co2 disparaisse de
l'atmosphère
il faut qu'ils reviennent au contact du
sol soit il est mangée par les plantes
et les plantes concevoir besoin
d'énergie c'est l'énergie du soleil
c'est la photosynthèse
soit il est repris par l'océan mais ça
c'est un pur problème de vases
communicants
si vous avez un peu plus d'espacé pour
mettre du co2 dans l'océan que dans
l'atmosphère est bien le seul ou deux
passes de l'atmosphère à l'océan
mais c'est un phénomène de vases
communicants c'est pas un phénomène
d'épuration chimiques
quelque part il est toujours là sauf
qu'il a changé deux compartiments et en
plus il a signifié l'océan et il peut
très bien en ressortir en particulier si
on chauffe l'océan le co2 ressort de
l'océan co2 n'aime pas l'eau chaude
il n'est pas se dissoudre dans l'eau
chaude et donc qui a pas de
séquestration éternelle du co2 une fois
qu'il est dans l'océan c'est juste un
processus d'équilibrage entre
l'atmosphère et l'océan
donc ce cette durée de vie très longue
du co2 dans l'atmosphère se
matérialisent sur le graphique que je
suis maintenant en train de vous montrer
à cause de nos émissions de gaz à effet
de serre nous avons augmenté la quantité
de co2 dans l'atmosphère au moment
où les hommes ont découvert les joies du
charbon on va dire il ya deux siècles
vous aviez dans l'atmosphère 200
millilitres par 280 en 2008 par mètre
cube ce qu'on appelle des millionième
280 milite par les reculs de co2
aujourd'hui vous en avez un peu plus de
410 quantité de co2 a augmenté
et bien si demain matin on arrêtait les
émissions le co2 présent dans
l'atmosphère ne va pas s'en aller
instantanément loin s'en faut
au bout d'un siècle vous avez à peu près
la moitié du surplus qui s'est emballé
la moitié seulement
l'autre moitié est toujours là au bout
d'un millénaire vous avez entre 20 et 30
pour ça
qui est toujours là et le climat de
début du 20e siècle
il est irrattrapable il est perdu à tout
jamais pour le restant des temps
historiques et en fait même le climat de
l'an 2000 il est perdu à tout jamais
pour le restant des temps historiques
on ne le reverra jamais il le climat de
l'an 2020 va s'en aller
à cause de cette inertie du co2 dans
l'atmosphère quoi qu'on fasse à partir
de maintenant et il faut bien comprendre
que en même temps qu'on a besoin de
réduire les émissions et des faire
disparaître le plus vite possible il
faut aussi qu'on s'adapte avec des riffs
climatique qui de toute façon va
s'amplifier à cause de cette inertie
absolument considérer donc ce sur quoi
j'insiste en ce moment et c'est
évidemment très désagréable parce que
nous sommes habitués à des arrêts
zorilla sur des packs temps beaucoup
plus court
c'est que de toute façon il est
impossible de remettre le système en
l'état
même quand on décide que la plaisanterie
a assez duré c'est juste impossible
et alors ce problème c'est que je donne
donc sur des pattes temps qui bien
évidemment vont 13 ou de l'arast d'une
vie humaine voire de plusieurs vies
humaines évidemment et surtout très très
au delà du patent que nous utilisons
qu'on gérer nos affaires
qu'il s'agisse des mandats politiques
qu'il s'agisse de la stratégie de long
terme dans une entreprise cotée et même
dans une entreprise pas coté il ya quand
même peu d'entreprises qui échappe à la
gestion de leur temps sur des horizons
cours si vous avez la malchance d'être
un sous traitant ou un fournisseur de
quelqu'un qui vous prêts sur un peu le
petit qui est bien votre pas de temps ça
va être votre plan de trésorerie à 3
mois ce qui est un peu court pour
s'occuper de la gestion de ce problème
donc c'est ça la l'un des sujets majeurs
dans le cadre du changement qu'a fait du
changement climatique c'est la symétrie
totale entre les pattes temps qui
caractérise le problème et l'épatant qui
caractérisent nos sociétés modernes
vous avez ici une courbe qui est la
traduction de la conséquence principale
qu'on retient quand on parle de
réchauffement climatique qui est que ça
se réchauffe
alors moi maintenant j'utilise de plus
en plus le terme de des riffs climatique
je le préfère à la notion de
réchauffement pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord réchauffement ça a véhiculé
plein de malentendus les gens sont dit
bon on enlèvera le pull un peu plus tôt
l'hiver et on est un peu plus tôt à la
plage d'été du reste il ya quelques
médias de temps en temps qui font des
marronniers avait qu'à regarder en avril
il faisait beau père laisse bédié c'est
quand même formidable ski week c'est sûr
mais le c'est pas du tout la seule
conséquence on va en voir d'autres
derrière ici en tout cas c'est pas la
conséquence que lui donnent les
physiciens parce que les physiciens
quand ils parlent de températures en
fait il parle d'énergie contenue dans un
système c'est sans vraiment qu'il y aura
de l'importance mais c'est plus
difficile à vulgariser alors ce que vous
voyez c'est que si on prend comme année
de référence objectivement période de
référence la deuxième moitié du 19e
siècle la température est resté stable
cette valeur de référence pendant la
deuxième moitié du 19e siècle a commencé
à augmenter la température moyenne de la
planète jusqu'à aujourd'hui
est ce que vous voyez c'est qu'à
l'avenir ça va se passer de façon très
discriminés à la fin du siècle en
fonction des émissions que nous allons
occasionnés donc ça on va dire en jaune
c'est une trajectoire type accords de
paris en rouge c'est une trajectoire où
on a plein de charbon de pétrole et de
gaz a brûlé et on est capable de les
brûler vient reviendrait à la fin je
pense même trajectoire est impossible
parce que le système craquera bien avant
ça et l'économie arrêtera croître bien
avant ça pour tout un tas de cause dont
le changement climatique mais ce que
vous voulez surtout de très important
c'est qu'en groupe d'ici à
allez on va dire la stimulation altema
en 2015 à fin 2010 2015 et rouler
qu'entre 2010 et 2040 à peu près toutes
les trajectoires emprunte le même chemin
donc ça c'est la conséquence de ce que
je viens de vous dire sur le l'inertie
du co2 dans l'atmosphère
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
évidemment une très mauvaise nouvelle
c'est que d'ici à ce que vos enfants et
votre âge
de toute façon quoi qu'on fasse sur les
émissions le climat délétère même
manière
quoi qu'on fasse sur les émissions d'ici
à ce que vos enfants et votre âge le
climat va à peu de choses près des rives
et de la même manière c'est évidemment
très désagréable comme conclusion parce
que ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas de [ __ ]
de frein qu'on peut actionner à bref
délai vous voyez que les deux degrés on
va les taper dans tous les cas de figure
je dis bien les cas de figure on tape
les deux degrés et l'accord de paris
permet de les taper une manière
transitoire et de descendre en dessous à
condition à condition que le système ne
s'emballe pas parce que je vais vous
montrer derrière des facteurs
d'emballement du système qui pour le
moment sont pas dans ces simulations là
et qui font que on pourrait très bien ne
pas y revenir ne pas revenir en dessous
des en dessous des 2 p alors pour
comprendre à quel point on est en train
de parler de quelque chose de très
important entre parle de quelques degrés
je vous propose maintenant deux petites
cartes que j'adore
la première c'est les écosystèmes qui
sont aujourd'hui capable de prospérer en
europe à condition qu'on leur fasse pas
de misère en les supprimant pour faire
des chants des routes des sièges sociaux
des écoles et des choses beaucoup plus
indispensables comme des stades de foot
voilà donc si on les supprime pas et
bien à ce moment ce que vous avez en
europe font que ce que vous aviez plus
exactement au xxème siècle en europe
parce que ça commence déjà à venir un
peu fou c'est essentiellement des
écosystèmes forestiers
c'est à dire qu'il pleut assez et il
fait ni trop froid ni trop chaud pour
qu'on ait des grosses d'espèces
végétales
c'est ça le ou les choses se passent
bien on va dire c'est un peu moins
luxuriant que ce que vous avez à
l'équateur c'est pas mal quand même
au nord la possèdent bien maigrichon
parce qu'il fait trop froid et trop sec
et à l'est ça devient maigrichon parce
qu'il fait trop sec
mais sinon ailleurs vous avez des gros
espèces végétales
voilà l'europe tire un bilan alors il ya
vingt mille ans dans le cadre des
oscillations naturelles du système
climatique dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure il fait beaucoup plus froid en
europe et il fait beaucoup plus froid
sur toutes les moyennes latitudes on est
dans ce qu'on appelle une ère glaciaire
alors la géographie européenne est un
tout petit peu différent d'abord on
pourrait pas avoir de commissaire
européen suédois finlandais
parce que tous ces braves gens sont sous
la glace ce que vous voyez également
c'est que le tournoi des six nations est
devenu un tournoi des quatre nations
puisque les irlandais et les écossais
sont aussi sous la glace vous avez une
énorme calotte glaciaire sur le canada
donc le québec libre n'existe pas et
vous avez une énorme car leur glacière
sur le nord de la sibérie
donc le l'hémisphère nord à une
physionomie qui est assez différente
pour faire ces groupes là sont donc
celui qui est leur appui celui des sur
le canada etc
il a fallu prendre de l'eau quelque part
l'eau a été prise dans l'océan et du
coup le niveau de l'océan a baissé de
plus de 100 m donc ya pas de points de
bris site puisque en bretagne qui n'est
pas sous la glace et la france donc
c'est inutile de se creuser la tête pour
savoir quel droit on va marier à quelle
reine pour éviter qu'on se tape dessus
de régler et voulait que la mer du nord
a également disparu
donc vous avez un évidemment la mer
baltique disparue la glace donc vous
avez un trait de côte qui s'est
énormément des plastiques le climat et
ambre ou plus froid il est beaucoup plus
sec et ce climat faisaient qu'ils feront
re a fait que ce que vous avez à la
latitude de la france vous voyez la même
latitude est bien en gros c'est ce que
vous avez aujourd'hui au nord de la
sibérie c'est à dire un mélange de
désert polaire de se taper de toundra
donc c'est pas trés trés luxuriants et
dans ce paysage pas extrêmement dans ces
écosystèmes par très gras pour nourrir
des animaux en bout de chaîne
alimentaire comme les hommes
et bien vous n'avez pas beaucoup de
monde vous voyez la totalité de la
population française de l'époque
c'est l'effectif salarié d'une grande
société aujourd'hui l'ordre de grandeur
que vous avez alors quand laurent est
passé de l'état de gauche à l'état de
droit'' évidemment ça s'est fait dans le
cadre d'un réchauffement planétaire et
bien ce réchauffement planétaire
il est de l'ordre de 5 degrés en disant
voilà en gros le réchauffement qui a
conduit l'europe à passer de cet état là
à cet état là c'est 5 degrés en dix
mille ans alors évidemment c'est 5
degrés ont été très bénéfiques
là on peut faire l'agriculture là on
peut pas donc dans ce monde
on a beaucoup moins de gens que dans ce
monde là c'est parfait il ya 40 35
degrés ça sera ça ira encore mieux ont
malheureusement ce n'est pas aussi
simple que ça un parallèle simple qu'on
peut faire c'est vous même quand vous
êtes passé de 0 à 20 ans on peut dire
que globalement la situation s'est
améliorée à peu près sur tous les plans
d'être devenu le plus grand plus fort et
plus et c'est tout va très bien
quand vous reprenez 20 ans
supplémentaires aux blacks te ment quand
vous passer de 50 à 70 c'est un peu
moins vrai que vingt ans de plus ça vous
arrange
donc l'idée est que chaque degré de plus
nous arranger malheureusement unités
naïve il faut pas avoir cette idée là en
tête
il faut regarder les choses de manière
plus plus approfondie et en fait quand
on les regarde de manière plus
approfondie on se rend compte que 5
degrés en un siècle ou 4 degrés en un
siècle ou 3 degrés en un siècle
c'est pas du tout une bonne affaire en
fait ça va être un choc ça va être une
énorme claque
et quand on voit ce que produit 5 degrés
en dix mille ans moi ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que 5 degrés en un siècle
ça sera la guerre partout c'est plutôt
comme ça qui c'est ça qu'il faut avoir
en tête parce que ça va impacter des
sociétés sédentaires et c'est la
stabilité du climat depuis dividendes
qui vous a permis de sédentariser ça va
impacter des sociétés sédentaires de 8
milliards d'individus et ça va créer des
déstabilisations et des défauts de
ressources qui feront que en pratique la
démocratie volera en éclats partout et
les gens vont se taper dessus voilà
c'est en gros ça qui va se passer
et dans ce problème dans ce monde là
notre premier problème ne sera pas de
savoir si la voiture auto dogme est une
bonne idée pour pouvoir lire son journal
pendant qu'on va au travail alors
quelques illustrations de ce que j'aime
venir ici vous avez une carte dans
laquelle les auteurs de cette étude ont
regardé le nombre de jours par an où les
conditions extérieures dépassait 35
degrés de température avec 100 %
d'humidité
et je vais vous dire après pourquoi ça
c'est mortel dans le monde avec une
température qui augmenterait de 4 devait
par rapport à 2000 donc de 5 degrés en
gros par rapport à au début du 20e
siècle
alors pourquoi est-ce que c'est lé
talent parce qu'il faut que la
température notre peau quand on la
température de votre peau est à peu près
à 35 degrés est par ailleurs vous avez
besoin de refroidir votre corps quand
vous êtes situés dans un air qui est à
plus de 35 degrés sinon vous bourrez
votre corps peut pas monter durablement
au dessus de 37 degrés sinon vous
m'auriez d'hyperthermie et pour pouvoir
évacuer de la chaleur de votre corps
quand la température extérieure est
supérieure à 35 degrés vous n'avez
qu'une seule manière de faire et vous la
connaissez très bien quand il fait très
chaud en france s'appelle la
transpiration transpirer suer à grosses
gouttes
alors qu'est ce qui se passe
physiquement quand vous transpirez vous
mettez de l'eau sur votre peau et cette
hausse est l'apport et en s'évaporant l
emporte avec elle de la chaleur et
emporte avec elle de l'énergie qui est
contenue dans votre corps et c'est comme
ça que votre corps mais si la air
extérieur est saturé d'humidité
s'il est à 100 % d'humidité l'eau qui
est à la surface de votre corps ne peut
pas s'évaporer il ya plus de place pour
elle dans l'atmosphère qui est déjà
saturé d'humidité et donc vous pouvez
plus refroidir votre corps donc si vous
êtes dans un air dont la température
extérieure est à plus de 35 degrés est
vous avez sans qu'on s'en d'humidité
vous ne pouvez plus sortir dehors sans
moyens en bout enfin instantanément mais
assez vite
et là vous voyez que ça concerne
potentiellement aller entre un et deux
milliards d'individus à l'horizon de la
fin du 21e siècle
alors vous comprenez bien que à deux
milliards d'individus qui peuvent plus
sortir dehors c'est plus de 300 jours
par an c'est un peu compliqué pour eux
quand même parce que pour les activités
agricoles par exemple ça pose quelques
petits sujets et bien évidemment ces
gens là vont pas rester là où ils sont
donc partie d'entre eux va vouloir aller
voir ailleurs le temps qu'il fallait
qu'elle veut dire et quand vous avez un
milliard d'individus compas envie de
rester amis sont bas ça fait un peu de
riffs ici un peu partout dans le monde
même et y compris en europe
deuxième conséquence du réchauffement
climatique c'est que vous allez avoir
une modification du cycle de l'eau et
cette modification du cycle de l'eau
elle va engendrer dans certains endroits
une augmentation des précipitations
moyennes une augmentation de l'humidité
des sols mais dans d'autres endroits
ça va engendrer une baisse des
précipitations et une baisse de
l'humidité des sols et on peut avoir les
sols qui deviennent beaucoup moins
humide même à précipitations constantes
il suffit pour cela que l'évaporation
augmente fortement et que les
précipitations se concentre sur quelques
épisodes intense dans l'année et qu'il
pleuve pas le reste du temps la csq est
en route pour le pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen que vous voyez ici et vous
voyez sur 7 comme l'humidité des sols en
fonction de l'élévation de température
est ce que vous voyez c'est donc à un
degré on perd 10 % d'humidité à deux
degrés on perdra consent d'humidité à 4
degrés on perd 40 % d'humidité des sols
si les soldes viennent plus c'est que
40% je peux vous dire qu'il poussera
plus grand chose
enfin en tout cas plus les mêmes choses
et que ça remonte jusqu'au centre de la
france donc il va y avoir des problèmes
de sécheresse des sols tu restes au
moment où je vous parle en ce moment on
est enfin on l email il ya déjà dans
quelques régions en france des problèmes
de sécheresse des sols
parce qu'il a très peu plu en mars et en
avril et les températures ont été
supérieures aux normes
j'ai envie de dire comme d'habitude donc
on va avoir un vrai problème dans un
certain nombre de régions dans le monde
et c'est souvent les régions à l'école
mais si je voulais pas montré une envie
l'ouest c'est pareil dans lesquels on va
avoir un problème croissant de stress
hydrique pour la végétation
alors ça ça va engendrer une baisse des
rendements alimentaire est ce que vous
dit le giec là sur le panneau sur le
truc de droite c'est que à partir de 2
degrés et demie d'élévation de la
température globale et bien l'insécurité
alimentaire devient généralisée et non
gérables ses salles
irrigation du code couleur violet s'est
généralisée et non gillard et non
gérables dans le monde un monde dans
lequel vous avez de l'insécurité
alimentaire généralisée et un monde
violent parce que l'histoire nous
enseigne que compte la disette
s'installe en général les gens n'aiment
pas ça et il se met à reculer
ici vous avez une carte qui vous donne
la fiabilité des forêts françaises
entre le début du xxième siècle que vous
avez là et la fin du 21e siècle avec un
scénario très émissifs mais
rappelez-vous que jusque entre la et là
de toute façon ce qui va se passer de
tellement pas du scénario des missions
puisque l'élévation enfin la dérive
climatique planétaire sera à peu près la
même dans tous les cas de figure en tout
cas pour la ce que vous voyez c'est
qu'avec un scénario émissifs à la fin du
siècle toutes les régions françaises
sauf rarissimes exceptions sont
inflammables comme l'arrière pays
méditerranéen aujourd'hui ces mêmes
codes couleurs que vous avez là et que
vous avez partout donc la forêt de
compiègne la forêt de chantilly la fois
qu intel plus haut pour ceux d'entre eux
connaissent un peu le bassin parisien
sarr bouffe disparu enfin disparu ça se
mettre à travailler exactement comme
l'arrière pays méditerranéen qui lui
sera extrêmement inflammable et du reste
une bonne partie des espèces végétales
naturelles
dans ce contexte là auront disparu et
puis de être par exemple dans cette
affaire là il ya quasiment plus de
certains est quasiment plus d'épicés en
bref c'est un monde dans lequel beaucoup
beaucoup d'espèces d'arbres que nous
avons aujourd'hui qui nous sont
familières sont sortis de leur zone de
confort de leur aire de répartition les
phénomènes extrêmes vont s'intensifier
ça c'est dû à de la physique de base
parce que le réchauffement climatique
ira de pair avec un refroidissement de
la stratosphère et à ce moment ça
augmente la différence de température
entre la surface et la haute atmosphère
et ça ça augmente la puissance de la
pompe convective qui met en route
les tornades les orages les ouragans
alors sur les ouragans les modèles ont
déjà une confusion à nous proposer qui
est que l'intensité unitaire va
augmenter dans les phénomènes seront
plus violents globalement sur les
tornades et les orages qui a pas de
conclusion parce que c'était trop petit
phénomène pour que les modèles qui ont
démarré un peu grosse puissent les
apprécier mais
le bon la logique j'ai envie de dire
voudrait que l'évolution à un peu dans
le même sens le groenland a commencé à
fondre
l'antarctique de l'ouest et en risque de
déstabilisation il ya un paquet qui
vient sortir d'un nature peu plus tard
que ce matin
en gros des paquets se multiplient
depuis quelques années pour dire que ce
gros glaçon là pour être totalement se
désintégrer dans les siècles qui
viennent
et ça ça fait six mètres dos en plus
dans l'océan mondial le foie landes a
commencé à fondre à l'échelle de
quelques siècles
ça fait 3 à 6 mètres dos en plus dans
l'océan mondial dont crimes sur sedo
truc là on est en train de jouer alors
ils sont quelques siècles avec dix
mètres dos en plus dans l'océan mondial
donc dépêchez-vous de vendre votre
maison un énorme pied
est ce que sur l'île de ré est ce que
vous voyez là pose évidemment la
question de toutes les implantations
humaines qui sont à bord de mer et vous
avez la moitié de la population mondiale
qui habite pas très très loin des côtes
alors paré pour pas être submergé et
s'impose également et d'énormes
questions sur les infrastructures
portuaires qui sont des infrastructures
de communication importante et qui vont
avoir des problèmes croissants dans ce
monde à la reprise du co2 par
l'atmosphère acidifie l'eau de mer je
voulais dit tout à l'heure un peu ou
beaucoup
ça c'est quelque chose qui est gênant
pour toutes les espèces qui ont besoin
de synthétiser du calcaire une partie du
second plancton les coraux une partie
des coquillages et c'est donc là c'est
la bouteille à l'encré
personne ne sait exactement quel effet
ça va avoir
parce que le ph de l'océan était très
très stable depuis au moins trente
millions d'années donc c'est très
difficile de savoir ce que ça va avoir
comme conséquence le la des lunes dans
l'atlantique ce qu'on a coutume
d'appeler le gulf stream en france mais
en fait c'est palio stream le mieux
serait de plus au sud et à risque de
s'affaiblir voire de s'arrêter
complètement
c'est un risque qui est aujourd'hui il a
commencé à se ralentir on le voit dans
les modèles
certains disent ça pourrait totalement
s'effondrer d'autres disent ça va juste
très sérieusement se ralentir sa valeur
c'est très difficile de savoir
c'est une instabilité de plus dans ce
système quand on chauffe le bouillon de
culture envers les petites bêtes aime
bien ça et le colis est bien évidemment
personne n'est capable de le relier au
réchauffement climatique mais il ya
d'autres maladies la taag la fièvre
jaune etc pour lesquels il ya déjà des
analyses qui permettent de relier
l'augmentation de leur aire de
répartition avec le réchauffement
climatique et c'est quelque chose qui
devrait s'accélérer
parce que la biodiversité des agents
pathogènes que vous pouvez voir là est
plus élevé qu'en vous rapprocher des
endroits où la température est élevée
bonsoir je vais passer rapidement et
enfin je vais finir sur la dernière
la dernière phrase nous sommes en train
de faire actuellement une expérience
grandeur nature
qui n'a pas de précédent dans l'histoire
humaine l'idéologique c'est à dire qu'un
réchauffement aussi rapide ou sur plus
appliqué à notre espèce aussi nombreuses
et sédentarisés il n'y a pas de
précédent dans l'histoire humaine et
vous êtes bien placé pour savoir où les
chefs d'entreprise que quand on fait une
expérience pour la première fois que
vous lancez pour la première fois un
produit vous recruter pour la première
fois une équipe entièrement nouvelle
vous absorbez un concurrent pour la
première et la seule chose dont vous
êtes absolument certain c'est que vous
n'avez pas tout prévu à l'avancé vous
aurez des surprises alors souvent quand
on se lance dans une aventure humaine
on se fait confiance sur le fait que les
surprises resteront à la mesure ce qu'on
est capable de gérer mais parfois c'est
pas le cas il ya des op 1 qui échoue il
ya des recrutements qui échoue il ya des
lancements de produits qui échoue et
certains et je suis tellement que ça
réussit à tuer une entreprise est bien
en ce qui concerne le réchauffement
climatique
la dérive climatique gardez à l'esprit
que la seule chose de certaine c'est
qu'on est incapable et quand je dis on
c'est la communauté scientifique est
totalement incapable qu'il ne faut pas
lui demander ça de voir venir toutes les
conséquences possibles à la vente et à
partir du moment où on fait une
expérience avec toutes les conséquences
possibles qui ne sont pas prévisibles
ça veut dire que nous aurons des
surprises c'est la définition même d'une
conséquence que vous n'avez pas dû dire
le coville est une surprise celle là on
verra un peu vu venir si on écoute les
virologues sans être capable de la dater
précisément et bien le changement
climatique c'est pareil ça va vous faire
décoller la répétition qui seront de
plus en plus en plus à mesure que le
temps passera
ça va vous faire des cygnes noirs sont
des trucs imprévus et donc il faut il
faut dire qu'à partir de maintenant
c'est pas business casual qu'il faut
avoir en tête c'est 'business as usual'
nous entrons dans un monde qui va être
un monde volatile pour partie
imprévisible avec des surprises à
l'essentiel d'entre elles étant
généralement pas très bonne voilà c'est
en ce monde là qu'il va falloir oublier
c'est dans ce monde là qu'il va falloir
avoir des plans qui vont nous permettre
de limiter la casse
c'est dans ce monde là qu'il va falloir
rêver et avoir de l'espoir c'est bien en
cela qu'il va falloir se diriger
alors si on veut limiter la casse c'est
quoi le cahier des charges vous avez ici
un graphique qui est issu de dernier
rapport plein du giec du d'un gros
rapports le prochain est attendu pour la
fin de l'année et l'année prochaine qui
vous donne le réchauffement global de la
planète en fonction de la quantité
totale de gaz à effet de serre que et en
particulier de co2 que nous mettrons
l'atmosphère donc ce que vous pouvez
constater ces caps après linéaire dit
autrement le réchauffement climatique au
premier rang aux dépens de façon
linéaire de la quantité totale de co2
que nous mettons dans l'atmosphère alors
le réchauffement est linéaire mais les
conséquences sont pas du tout linéaire
je vais prendre un exemple qui vous
parlera je l'espère qui votre propre
corps vous prenons plutôt le corps d'un
enfant d'un jeune enfant douce et bien
si le nourrisson un jour il ya un coup
de fièvre et que sa température passe de
37 à 38 degrés vous n'êtes pas plus
inquiet que sarah vous dites bon il a un
petit coup de chaud là c'est pas grave
il suffit d'attendre ça va passer mais
si il a pas un degré d'élévation de
température mais 5 degrés l'élévation de
température je peux vous dire que vous
allez devenir sacrément fébrile en vous
demandant s'il va pas y passer
eh bien c'est exactement la même chose
donc 5 degrés c'est pas cinq fois plus
grave qu un degré bien d'autres seront
pas grave et donc cinq fois pas grave
eh bien c'est exactement pareil en ce
qui concerne le réchauffement climatique
les conséquences à 2 degrés c'est pas
deux fois les conséquences à un degré
c'est être mille fois les conséquences à
un degré et les conséquences à 4 degrés
c'est pas 4 fois les conséquences à un
degré c'était un million de fois les
conséquences à un degré donc il faut
qu'il faut se sortir de la tête ce qu'on
va hurler coutume d'appeler l'illusion
linéaire et qui est d'autant plus forte
dans le monde économique les règles de 3
et les rêves de proportionnalité on fait
ça en permanence un chauffe-eau ou 1000
euros de chauffe eau des vidéos route
chauffe-eau 3000 euros enfin on n'arrête
pas de raisonner de manière linéaire
dans le monde économique dans le monde
physique
c'est plutôt l'exception de la règle
mais là vous avez quand même une règle
linéaire
entre deux grandeurs qui sont
réchauffement global et pas les
conséquences encore une fois et les
émissions cumulées alors à fin 2010 8
notre espèce avait rajouté un peu plus
de 2000 milliards de tonnes de co2 dans
l'atmosphère large partie est encore là
il faut qu'on limite les émissions à
3000 milliards de tonnes les émissions
totales jusqu'à la fin du 21e siècle
dont 2200 de 1300 ont déjà été élise ça
veut dire qu'il reste à l'avenir en gros
la moitié vendre le tiers
si on veut tenir la corde paris et ça
veut dire en gros que les émissions
doivent baisser de 5% par an à partir de
maintenant
allez on va dire pour les quelques
décennies qui viennent 5% c'est la
baisse que nous avons eues en 2020 à
cause du coc vide donc retenu n'est que
pour tenir les deux degrés de l'accord
de paris il nous faut un acolyte
supplémentaires tous les ans et bien
évidemment quand je vous dis ça je suis
en train de vous dire une chose que vous
comprenez tout de suite de manière
intuitive
ça n'est pas compatible avec la
croissance économique donc on ne fera
pas les 2 degrés dans un monde en
croissance économique
donc il va falloir choisir ou bien on
veut la croissance est en ce moment à
vienne que poids sur les conséquences du
changement climatique
donc ça passe ou bien on veut vraiment
préserver l'environnement et on se
trouve d'autres projets pour la dire que
de vouloir faire augmenter sans cesse la
taille de l'économie alors dans les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre qui
ont pas raté d'augmenter il ya une cause
qui est très importante qui est
l'augmentation de la quantité d'énergie
on utilise et vous voyez que depuis un
siècle et demi le pétrole est venu en
plus du charbon le gaz est plus en plus
du pétrole
l'hydroélectricité du capital et là vous
avez ce qui excite tout le monde a en ce
moment les nouvelles énergies
renouvelables vous n'en avez plein les
articles de journaux en fait vous voyez
ce que ça représente
au regard de la quantité totale
d'énergie qu'on mobilise dans le monde
pour le moment ça vaut à peine l'encré
sur le papier
alors vous allez me dire oui mais plus
tard très bien on en reparlera enfin
pour le moment c'est pas majeur ce que
vous voyez c'est que gbagbo il n'y a pas
d'évolution en particulier l'arrivée des
services dans l'économie va vous voyez
que ça n'a strictement pas infléchi
l'évolution de cette courbe salaire un
peu calme et lisse a augmenté plus vite
avance
un peu moins vite après et l'essentiel
de cette énergie c'est des énergies
fossiles qui est trois questions alors
on peut se demander comme quoi cette
comédie très bien on consomme de plus en
plus d'énergie pour quand j'ai entendu
dire que la meilleure énergie c'est
celle qu'on ne consomme est pas alors
comment ça se fait parce que là
manifestement on en consomme de plus en
plus donc on n'a pas dû bien dégoûté
alors en fait il ya eu une très bonne
raison à ce qu'on ait fait ça là aussi
je vous présente ironman alors c'est
quoi et rodman et bien c'est par un
exosquelette j'avais une armure qu'on
met sur soi surpuissante et bien
l'énergie c'est iron man
alors il se trouve que iron man pour
nous à pas cette tête là il a c'est
peut-être là voyez bon pendant la tête
d' ironman
on peut pas dire que ça ça ressemble à
un ironman et ça ça ressemble iron man
est en fait cet ironman en pièces
détachées
pourquoi parce que c'est ton jardin il
est puissant comme dit mille fois la
paire de bras puissante pardon comme des
centaines de milliers de fois des
millions de fois les paires de bras des
gens qui travaillent de même que cette
chaîne elle est puissante comme des
milliers ou des dizaines de milliers de
fois les paires de bras et c'est donc en
fait ici vous avez un démultiplicateur
de notre force musculaire et l'énergie
c'est des croquettes pour ses machines
donc l'énergie c'est des croquettes pour
machines c'est pas vous ni moi qui
consomment ou l'énergie ou quoi pas le
pétrole quand on dit qu on augmente
notre consommation d'énergie en fait ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est qu'on
augmente la taille de notre costume
d'iron man on augmente la quantité de
machines ont fait bosser à notre place
voilà c'est ça augmenter la consommation
d'énergie c'est pour ça qu'on l'a fait
on est tous devenus des esclavagistes en
puissance nous sommes tous devenus des
nababs des aristocrates et on a le temps
d'assister à des conférences pendant
toutes ces machines font de vêtements
cultive notre nourriture assure notre
système de soins etc
c'est les machines qui bosse à notre
place aujourd'hui qui façonnent
quitterais fils qui engloutissent qui
chauffe qui refroidissent etc
tout ça c'est des machines qu'ils font
pour nous et on a vraiment construit
ironman
je le redis pour de vrai grâce à
l'énergie si je vous propose un tout et
calcul d'heures de grandeur en fait la
puissance des machines dans deux
disposant sur terre a permis de
multiplier par plusieurs centaines la
puissance des muscles de lui
j qui sont les croquettes pour machines
spéciales pour faire le même pib sans
machine
il faudrait que la population planétaire
passe à 1600 milliards d'individus
je vais vous dire encore autrement le
smicard français vit comme s'il avait
500 esclaves à sa disposition
comparé aux paysans il ya deux siècles
le smicard français est un nabab
voilà c'est ça l'énergie c'est ça
qu'elle nous a permis de faire et c'est
pour ça qu'on en a jamais assez
avoir un monde 100% énergies
renouvelables c'est tout à fait possible
ça pose aucun problème
voilà un exemple demande 100 %
renouvelable on a bien connu vous avez
ici une barque en bois renouvelables qui
naviguent sur une rivière renouvelables
avec la une perche en bois renouvelables
et un batelier renouvela vous aviez
éventuellement décidé d'armer un moulin
avec du grand renouvelables tout ça
était parfaitement renouvelables donc
faire un monde sans qu'on s'en fout en
l'air ça ne pose aucun problème
alors je dis bien aucun problème faire
un monde pour 8 milliards d'individus
voulant vivre comme un smicard français
100% renouvelable
vous me verrez jamais de votre vie
j'avais ça n'arrivera jamais c'est
physiquement impossible parce que les
énergies fossiles sont considérablement
supérieurs physiquement aux énergies
renouvelables
et c'est bien pour ça que dans ce monde
là vous n'avez pas de civilisation
industrielle qui est apparu il a duré
dix mille ans ce monde là où l'a
amélioré on a fait des couleurs à un peu
plus efficace des bateaux à voile un peu
plus efficace et on n'a pas fait si lisa
sion industriels alors que les gens
étaient aussi intelligent qu'aujourd'hui
donc le puisque la cervelle humaine n'a
pas tellement changé donc le la raison
pour laquelle le monde industriel est
arrivé c'est les énergies fossiles qui a
permis de faire une nouvelle génération
de machines
enfin qui ont permis de faire une
nouvelle génération de machines
voilà donc je finis cette intervention
en vous montrant qu aujourd'hui on est
dans une situation qui est pas simple la
situation pas simple dans laquelle on
est c'est que en gros ou bien on essaye
de repousser un peu tant que cela passe
près limites planétaires pour avoir une
économie qui continue à être en
expansion et à ce moment on se prendra
une gueule de bois
d'autant plus sévère que on
des effets de farm des effets de retour
qui seront importants dont la dérive
climatique ou bien on dit non non on va
se mettre au régime tout de suite on a
bien compris et à ce moment ça n'est pas
compatible avec la croissance économique
il faut contracter l'économie donc vous
avez ici alors dans ce scénario la
l'économie fini par se contracter au sia
sous le coup de la diversité c'est à
dire manque de ressources réchauffement
climatique etc
voilà le monde dans lequel on est et
c'est dans ce monde là qu'il faut
trouver une raison d'espérer pour
l'avenir
alors je vais juste finir avec ça peu de
recul c'est à peu près à ce programme là
qu'on essaye en ce moment de travailler
au chic project depuis un an maintenant
c'est à dire depuis le début du coup
vide qui a quand même sauvé quelques
personnes avaient fait comprendre que
les mauvaises surprises ça pourrait
exister
on s'est mis à la planche à dessin pour
essayer de faire un programme qui
permette de concilier le respect des
limites planétaires au premier chef
desquels le climat dont je viens de vous
parler et quand même le fait que les
gens aient un job et regarde l'avenir
avec un peu de confiance et on a appelé
ça le plan de transformation de
l'économie française donc c'est comment
est-ce qu'on marie la sobriété et
l'emploi si je suis je dis les choses de
manière un peu claires est ce qu'il faut
c'est qu'on ait un plan qui flottent
même en cas de contraction du pib et
comment est ce qu'on fait pour les quand
même content de lire content d'être
ensemble et je leur dis qu'on est espoir
en regardant l'avenir dans seconde la
voilà donc c'est très difficile exercice
qu'on s'est attelée et on vient de faire
un appel aux entreprises mentionnent un
patient pour essayer d'obtenir à la fois
du soutien et une réfutation nos idées
dans le cadre de ce plan qui est une
première et dont on espère qu'il sera
utile à la collectivité
voilà j'ai été un tout petit peu long et
maintenant place aux questions avec ce
plaisir sur scène on vous impose
on vous en prie virtuellement et voilà
les défis que deux ans et demi qu'on
sourit
pendant donc je me suis posé beaucoup de
questions vient de la vermont frédéric
et aymeric puisque ce que je vous
propose maintenant c'est de passer aux
questions de nos auditeurs de nombreuses
questions elles sont posées l'une à plus
d'une soixantaine
alors malheureusement on prend pas y
répondre
et vous non plus jean marc jancovici est
tout
aujourd'hui on va les gains des deux
côtés on pourra donc que les traités
après avec vous donc j'en ai une
la première question ariane on va donc
regarder aussi avec vous les questions
de nos auditeurs
la première est celle ci pourquoi jean
marc jancovici considère il veut que la
première des choses à faire pour un
entrepreneur je trouvais que beaucoup
d'entrepreneurs qui nous regardent et
deux comtés ses émissions alors la
première des choses à faire
quand on a un problème c'est de disposer
d'une méthode qui permettent de
comprendre à quelle distance on est du
problème
j'ai envie de dire l'entité quand on a
la charge et a dispersé les du problème
le problème que je viens d'évoquer
jusqu'à maintenant est absolument pas
dans l'unité que les entrepreneurs que
nous sommes puisque j'en suis fière
aussi je suis co dirigeant le quart 24
et puis on peut considérer que le chili
project est une entreprise
enfin oui dans une une aventure
entrepreneuriale pour le plus précis
même si c'est pas une entreprise et
c'est une association on la seule unité
de contre on manipule tous les jours
dans le cadre de cette activité c'est la
monnaie euro objectivement celle qui est
commune à tout le monde
cdo alors il se trouve que
conventionnellement dans les euros la
nature vos héros c'est comme ça c'est
comme ça depuis deux siècles depuis
qu'on a théorisé l'économie classique
donc si vous fabriquez des bouteilles en
verre la mise à disposition par mère
nature de sable et le carbonate de
calcium
ça vaut zéro ce qui vaut quelque chose
c'est la sueur des gens pour aller le
chercher mais le fait que la ressource
existe ça vaut 0 pourtant si cette
ressource n'existait pas on ferait pas
de berre donc si on veut en ski et le
climat exactement pour les mêmes raisons
au 0 le système climatique planétaire
vos héros vous n'avez dans aucun
décompte des gens qui nous regardent une
ligne quelque part dans leur
comptabilité pour l'existence du système
climatique
vous n'avez pas une ligne quelque part
pour l'existant
c'est un pur sang d'oxygène dans l'air
que pourtant s'il ya plus d'oxygène dans
l'air il ya plus de comptes du parc
serait tous morts
et en ce qui concerne le climat comme le
système climatique aux héros et que le
monde physique aux héros dans l'économie
qu'on manipule on est obligé si on veut
comprendre à quelle distance on est du
problème physique d'avoir une
comptabilité physique
séparée de la comptabilité monétaire
parce que le carbone n'est pas dans les
autres on peut rien faire sur le carbone
à partir d euros donc on est obligé de
mettre en place une comptabilité
distincte qui s'appelle la comptabilité
carbone
alors quand elle est bien faite parce
qu'elle peut être mal fait comme toute
comptabilité c'est pour ça qu'on a des
commissaires aux comptes pour vérifier
qu'on fait bien la comptabilité
quand elle est bien faite cette
comptabilité carbone elle vous donne de
la visibilité surtout les processus dont
dépend des et je dis bien dont vous
dépendez
donc vous pouvez très bien dépendre de
processus qui pour autant n'ont pas la
moindre contrepartie comptable dans vos
comptes
donc le bilan carbone il est là pour
vous donner cette visibilité et à partir
du moment où vous avez cette visibilité
vous êtes capable de réfléchir à la fois
risquée impact c'est à dire vous êtes
capable de vous dire voilà si un tel
endroit on peut plus émettre de gaz à
effet de serre qu'est ce que je deviens
donc imaginons par exemple vous êtes
jeunes vous êtes choc dirigeants vous
êtes le fournisseur extrêmement
scrupuleux d'un restaurant gastronomique
vous fait que des légumes qui vous
parlez tous les jours avec amour ou
caresser la fan de chaque carottes tous
les jours vous la passe est au plus haut
vous fonctionnez avec de l'autre source
et vous vous dites moi j'ai pas de
risque dans cette affaire parce que je
fais vraiment ou bien est en fait vous
vous rendez compte que le restaurant qui
vous font ni sénat que des gens qui
viennent en avion
et bien ça c'est pas du tout dans votre
compte un accord nulle part dans votre
compte 1 il est dit que les gens du
restaurant que vous fournissez bien dans
l'avion dans ce cas là vous d'être
extrêmement à risque parce que des
commandes et d'un processus qui est
transport aérien et si j'avais ce
transport aérien la pluie aux élans vous
y passez aussi donc le l'empreinte
carbone doit permettre de raisonner
risque en même temps qu'elle résonne
impact c'est à dire un pacte c'est
qu'est-ce que je peux faire à mon niveau
pour
les choses alors là en l'occurrence
c'est pas vous qui choisissez la
clientèle du restaurant par contre vous
pouvez changer de restaurant
si vous avez un restaurant qui
n'accueille que des français qui
viennent à vélo et bien vous vous des
risques et par rapport aux risques que
je viens d'évoquer mais pour prendre
cette décision
vous devez savoir d'où donc de vous
partez voilà donc j'espère qu'avec cet
exemple j'ai fait comprendre le fait que
pour savoir d'où l'on part il faut une
comptabilité approprié qui s'appelle la
comptabilité carbone et comme
malheureusement n'y a pas de repas
gratuits
cette comptabilité carbone si on veut la
déployer il faut y mettre des moyens
aujourd'hui ce que je constate dans le
monde économique c'est que les moyens
sont encore très insuffisant pour
déployer ce genre de comptabilité au
niveau où ça permet de commencer à
arbitrer des décisions j'ai envie d'air
pour de vrai hors de question
ariane jean-marc si vous pouvez répondre
rapidement parce que nous en avons
beaucoup de questions comme ça mais peu
de temps qui nous reste à rien alors
j'enchaîne sur une question de stéphanie
brunet afin de réduire notre empreinte
carbone mais ce soit au niveau des
entreprises ou à titre individuel quelle
est la première chose la plus des carbo
nantes sur laquelle nous devons tous
agir immédiatement
qu'est ce qui a le plus d'impact et bien
la réponse c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
réponse
si je perds un haut fourneau ce qui a le
plus d'impact c'est de réduire le
minerai de fer d'hydrogène au lieu de le
réduire au charbon si je perds un avion
ce qui a le plus d'impact c'est de faire
voler moins d'avions et si je jean
paquette des champignons ce qui a le
plus d'impact et probablement d'avoir la
clientèle la plus local possible
donc la réponse c'est qu'il ya pas de
réponse c'est exactement comme si on me
posait la question je gagne pas assez
d'argent qu'est ce que je fais pour
gagner plus où je perds de l'argent
qu'est ce que je fais pour en perdre
moins value ça dépend voilà donc alors
sur les individus les habitudes de
consommation sont quand même beaucoup
plus standard j'ai envie de dire tout ce
temps qu'on a on mange aussi aux gens se
déplacent et c'est là vous avez un outil
qui pour les particuliers est en libre
accès et qui est payant pour les
entreprises dont la grande philosophie
communiste de quart 24 qui s'appelle my
si au tout
my comme le mien elle y est si haut de
co2 comme co2 et qui permet de
comprendre où on en est avec sa propre
empreinte carbone et ça peut être une
mise de pied à l'étrier mais sur une
entreprise il faut c'est retour à la
question précédente faut commencer par
faire le diagnostic c'est à dire le
bilan carbone un peu exhaustif et
ensuite et ensuite seulement on commence
à se gratter la tête pour savoir ce
qu'on fait une autre question
jean-marc croyez vous encore possible
que l'europe atteigne son objectif de
neutralité entre guillemets en 2050
alors la réponse est tout à fait oui si
on a une pandémie une guerre
thermonucléaire ou voilà est-ce qu'on
peut y arriver dans un contexte de
croissance économique pas une seconde
est ce qu'on peut y arriver dans un
contexte même de pib constant tu traites
de ge j'en doute beaucoup
est ce que l'europe a compris que
c'était un sac elle s'engageait c'est à
dire avoir une économie en contraction
pour elle a dit qu'elle allait être
neutre sûrement pas parce que
aujourd'hui le débat climatique est
rendu très début le par les économistes
qui manipulent des modèles dans lesquels
le monde physique n'existent pas donc
pour eux ça pose pas de problème que ya
la croissance économique en même temps
qu'on soit sérieux sur ce sujet là ce
qui explique les engagements comprend la
réalité c'est que c'est que non donc la
seule chose que je sais c'est que le
plan européen et qui est un plan de
croissance verte mais qui est le même en
france puisqu'on a vu loin pour la
croissance verte qui est pas après ce
qui arrivera jeudi dans ok si vous
murmurer à l'oreille des manuels macron
quelle est la mesure que vous rajoutez
riez dans la loi climat et résilience
qui vient d'être votée à l'assemblée
celles qui manquent j'en rajouterai 259
parce que en fait la première chose que
je dirais emmanuel macron si surya son
oreille je peux vous le dire parce que
je les ai déjà fait pas directement à
son oreille mais à l'oreille de
plusieurs de ses conseillers c'est un
point le son point courant pour le
moment tu causes d'un truc que tu
connais pas
donc prendre leçon le c'est évident que
pour commencer à gérer un problème il
faut en avoir à peu près les contours en
tête il a jamais eu leçons là-dessus à
l'ena rahila j'avais eu le son est
passée par là il a il a jamais eu le
sont après chez rothschild ça c'est sûr
dans carmes à un moment faut pas un coup
je lui proposais bien excellent qui a
été mentionné tout à l'heure mais après
il n'y a pas une mesure a rajouté dans
le gros clients puisque s'occuper du
monde physique c'est changer l'ordre de
prééminence
comme je le disais tout à l'heure entre
durée et profitez-en c'est vraiment ça
le sujet c'est à dire on va profiter -
tout de suite enfin nous en tout cas on
va moins se goberger matériellement et
on va durer plus longtemps ça ne relève
pas d'une mesure et d'une seule ça
relève d'une vie ça relève d'une vision
du monde
alors une question non pas des auditeurs
dire que nous en avons d'autres
frédérique bedos je vous vois réagir en
faisant voisine que vous avez une
question pour jean marc j'ai un grand
grand merci
jean-marc effectivement ce que j'aime
c'est que il ya une vraie pédagogie vous
nous emmenez pour qu'on comprenne et
comprennent la mesure en même temps
évidemment ça résonne comme un coup de
massue
parce que ben vrai ça fait pas parfait
bien sûr ça fait peur et en même temps
moi je rejoins jean marc c'est à dire
que il ya une urgence et si on est
vraiment nombreux a vraiment réalisé le
7 urgences alors peut-être qu'on va
commencer vraiment à se bouger et je
pense que là dessus on se rend bien
compte que il faut une pression
populaire sur tous nos dirigeants sur
toutes les sphères de décision au niveau
national et international puisqu'on
parle de problèmes globaux
donc je pense que peut-être la première
des choses c'est effectivement que de
manière individuelle en prenne
conscience pour pouvoir véritablement
s'engager et se dire ok comment on va
faire en sorte de créer quelque chose de
lors d'un mouvement qui va qui va
finalement donner les mains libres
décisionnaire pour véritablement agir
tant qu' ils sont dans des temps courts
moi ma prochaine élection dans quelques
mois dans quelques années on avoir des
mandats très court qui l'a en fait sont
en train d'écrire
lisez le modèle démocratique puisque en
fait si on part sur ce modèle là il faut
avoir une vision à long terme alors d'un
seul coup on se dit ah plus que les
totalitarismes qu'ils peuvent me faire
des plans à long terme
bon c'est quand même un vrai problème
donc il ya il ya un vrai sujet de de
géopolitique et de et de manière de
gérer le monde
ça c'est la première chose et donc je
pense qu'aujourd'hui justement à l'ère
des réseaux sociaux a l'air d'une
jeunesse qui elle est totalement
déconnecté globalisé afin qu'à une
vision de d'une citoyenneté mondiale
il ya quelque chose là qui se joue est
juste cette question d'après ce que je
comprends vous n'êtes pas du tout un
adepte de cette idée de la croissance
verte
cette idée qu'on pourrait effectivement
préserver la croissance économique tout
en faisant de l'écologie et en
préservant l'équilibré est ce que je me
trompe jean-marc pas d'eto'o et là je
vais aller encore plus loin que ça je
pense que malheureusement en france la
croissance a déjà plus là quand on
regarde les indicateurs physiques de
l'économie européenne française et
européenne sur la construction par
exemple on est passé par un maximum dans
les constructions en europe en 2007 et
depuis ça commence à décroître gentiment
on est passé par un maximum de la
quantité de marchandises 30 renter dans
les camions en 2007 et depuis ça roule à
riace par hasard ce soit 2007 mais
aujourd'hui j'ai pas le temps pour les
explications et donc je pense qu'en fait
elle est déjà là rhin simplement l
épargne souvent les gens qui participent
à la conférence telles que celles que je
donne aujourd'hui mois pour pendant
savais pas ce que je fais je suis je
fais partie des csp + et je suis dans
une niche où j'ai pas de problème pour
trouver du boulot
elle y parle souvent les gens qui
viennent à des conférences parce que
toute façon quand vous êtes déjà à
moitié à la rue et que tout ce que tout
ce qui vous reste c'est d'aller c'est
d'aller acheter des trucs chez emmaüs
toute façon vous n'avez pas le temps de
participer à des conférences pour ça que
vous faites donc souvent les gens dont
les conférences s'en rendent pas compte
parce qu'ils font partie des privilégiés
qui sont encore épargnés par l'évolution
mais le regard des évolutions électorale
où un certain nombre d'indicateurs pour
se rendre compte
que le problème en fait il est déjà là
donc la croissance allait déjà en
pratique parti depuis 2007
depuis on a essentiellement de la fosse
croissance l'inflation d'actifs les
mètres carrés qui augmente et c'est de
la vraie croissance les tables et
chaises des voitures sait déjà c'est
déjà terminé quelque part mais c'est pas
une raison pour et espérait donc ce que
je crois c'est que il est surtout urgent
de comprendre où sont des canaux d'un
lock up comprendre le cadre dans lequel
il faut raisonner et de sacs est à la
tâche pour pour de vrai et donc de
commencer par mettre du jus tiers où
l'attend ce que pour le moment nous ne
faisons pas sur le monde politique oui
en démocratie le monde politique réagit
enfin où exactement se s'adapte aux
pressions qu'on peut lui lui envoyer
alors je fais pas ça souvent d'habitude
mais je vais le faire pour une fois je
réitère aux entrepreneurs qui nous
écoute que si vous pensez qu'il faut
s'occuper de ce problème
eh bien on sera ravi aussi project de
vous compter parmi les soutiens de notre
plan de transformation même si vous
savez pas ce cap dans un premier temps
regarder parce qu on a déjà pas mal
publié sur le sur la question et c'est
comme ça je pense
que on matérialise un nombre à un moment
pour matérialiser un nombre donc faut
créer un parti et scélérat gauchissement
par les deux parties mais un moment sont
matérialisés un nombre ya pas tellement
d'autres manières d'exister dans le
débat démocratique que matérialiser un
nombre parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
est perçu comme pouvant exercer un
pouvoir de nuisance même si c'est pas
vrai et donc on est écouté
[Musique]
oui oui je voulais réagir sur parce que
c'est très à-propos par rapport à ce que
jean marc disait et par rapport à ce que
frédéric tu disais tout à l'heure c'est
déjà il ya deux postes sur 16 ont parlé
politique mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui
si on est là aussi c'est parce qu'il
faut intégrer que doit rien attendre des
politiques est qu'il nous faut prendre
nos responsabilités nous en tant que
chef d'entreprise et non en tant que
citoyen ne peut pas se cacher derrière
en se disant c'est la faute des autres
nous sommes complices tous les jours
dans nos actions et donc c'est aussi
pour ça qu'on veut amener la bonne
parole et faire en sorte de montrer
qu'il ya les cadeaux en incapacité à
faire et déjà bouger des choses sans
attendre que tous viennent des autres ça
c'est une première chose à laquelle je
voulais réagir et la deuxième chose
auquel nous sommes absolument convaincus
aussi gide est en train d'y travailler
on y travaille depuis longtemps c'est
sur l'immatériel et ça devrait pouvoir
nous réunir tous les trois j'allais dire
par rapport à son le seul dans ton luth
c'est que nous lui parlons de croissance
mais nous parlons de croissance sur la
capacité à consommer plus de trucs plus
de choses tant que nous jugerons la
croissance sur la base de la
consommation de plus de choses on se
trompera et nous n'arrivons pas et si
toutefois nous jugeons la croissance
d'une société sur l'immatériel sur ce
qui nous rend plus heureux sur la notion
du bonheur qui est très subjective mais
sur des choses du concours est sur le
capital humain on parle de capital
humain dans nos entreprises
on parle de bien-être et si la finalité
du monde était celle ci pourquoi alors
continuons nous a jugé la réussite du
monde par rapport à sa croissance à
consommer des choses voilà c'est tout
jean-marc aller jusque là dessus en fait
le problème il est souvent le côté de la
barrière
je vais prendre un exemple imaginons
qu'une partie des gens
10 tiens je vais arrêter de j'habite en
banlieue je vais arrêter d'aller au
boulot en voiture je vais y aller en
vélo électrique trucs beaucoup de gens
peuvent se mettre comme ça
instantanément aux vélos électriques ça
on peut ajuster l'assistance de telle
sorte que même si on fait pas d'exercice
ça soit pas difficile en fait en plus
donc on se mettra à faire un peu
d'exercice est plutôt bon ça va coûter
moins cher parce que un vélo électrique
c'est 1500 où environ 1500 euros une
voiture neuve 9 par une voiture neuve
c'est plutôt entre dix et vingt mille
bref la question à ce moment c'est que
justement comme le vélo électrique vaut
moins cher que la voiture c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des gens qui
fabriquent des voitures actuellement
parce qu'il n'y en aura pas besoin de
temps pour fabriquer des vélos
électriques puisque c'est moins cher et
en fait c'est de ce côté là en général
qu'il faut chercher la résolution du
problème donc la déconsommation pour
reprendre le terme va de pair avec
comment est-ce qu'on reconverti les gens
vers quoi on le dirige comment est-ce
qu'on peut que l'équation et on fait en
sorte que aussi les gens gagnent un peu
moins les biens leurs charges baissent
aussi et que du coup ils soient pas pris
à la gorge et c'est autour de ce genre
de questions qu'on va notamment
travailler dans le cadre du plan de
transformation de l'économie française
parce que c'est souvent les angles morts
dans les raisonnements militants en
disant ne porterait pas plus mal si on
avait moins
oui ça peut être vrai mais tant qu'on
n'a pas bouclé de l'autre côté il ya un
point du raisonnement qui n'est pas
couvert et ça ça fait peur à tout le
monde parce que les gens comprennent
bien que si on consomme moins en
fabriquera - et que si on fabrique - il
ya un risque pour leur job
donc ça c'est un c'est un truc qu'il
faut absolument qu'on traite et ça va
être vraiment un gros point de
d'investissement intellectuelle
j'entends dans le plan qu'on est en
train d'essayer de mettre au point les
questions de notre nos auditeurs comment
faire entrer tout cette pédagogie au
sein des organisations
la pesée goji pardon sofitel pour faire
passer à l'action
déjà la première question est évidemment
le tout sans faire peur à nos dirigeants
ou dirigeants
alors la réponse est ce que ça suffit
pour faire passer à l'action non les
gens qui vont rapidement passer à
l'action après un effort de pédagogie
c'est ce donc c'est ce qu'ils vont se
rendre compte que ce qu'ils sont déjà en
train de faire est plutôt du bon côté de
la barrière alors à ce moment-là cela
ils vont redoubler d'efforts ils vont
devenir beaucoup plus militant évadés
regardez comme c'est important de
s'occuper du problème étant que les
autres il y en a quelques-uns qui vont
commencer à regarder problèmes
existentiels
il faut bien réfléchir ils vont
réfléchir le matin en se rasant l'autre
une fois deux fois trois fois en 4 x 5 x
10 x
et puis après il y aura a déclenché un
sou vent qui va venir se rajouter à la
pédagogie alors le déclencheur ça peut
être pour les gens qui ont mon âge leur
enfant qui leur passent une danse ça
c'est un décor assez efficace vous
pouvez avoir une rencontre personnelle
vous pourrez il ya souvent un élément
personnel dans le fait de passer à
l'action à un moment ou un autre dans
les dirigeants de grandes entreprises
comme un jeune artisan du patrimoine des
failles en arriver à bout de forêt puis
il a vu son coût de forêt cramer mangés
par les spolient toucher quoi où il ya
un coup de fer il est arrivé là john
donc le la pédagogie c'est un élément
supplémentaire qui vient se rajouter
dans le dispositif bien évidemment elle
ne prétend pas à elle toute seule
faire passer à l'action mais elle est
indispensable elle est indispensable
parce que sans elle les gens font passer
à l'action b ils vont pas comprendre
exactement ce qu'ils font et ils ont
toutes les chances de taper au hasard et
taper au hasard ça peut faire empirer
les problèmes et non pas les résoudre
et donc c'est une brique indispensable
c'est loin d'être la seule mais c'est
une brique indispensable sur les
dirigeants
j'ai déjà répondu à moitié tout à
l'heure en fait le problème c'est
malheureusement long mais je connais pas
d'autre manière de faire se reprend à la
base tant que vous n'avez pas changé la
base vous n'avez pas changé la tête
c'est très très difficile dans un
mouvement quel qu'il soit
souvent vous avez des élections à un
autre des élections à la cfdt syndicat
de salariés vous avez des élections au
sein des assemblées générales vous allez
c'est donc temps que vous avez un
processus électif il faut partir de là
bas tu es donc frédéric a tout à fait
raison car remarquer qu'il ya les
monarchies et les dictatures qui échappe
la démocratie est une création récente
dans l'histoire des hommes et elle est
apparue au même moment que la croissance
économique est apparu donc ça devrait
nous faire réfléchir
là aussi je pense qu'il est urgent de
bien réfléchir à la façon dont on peut
conserver un monde démocratique dans un
univers en contraction économique
une autre question des auditeurs via la
chaîne la prise de conscience sur cette
réalité est heureusement de plus en plus
partagée notamment par les jeunes
générations quels conseils pour eux face
à l'anxiété et au sentiment
d'impuissance que c'est la provoc les
jeunes générations ils sont très
ambivalents sur ce sujet parce que c'est
les jeunes générations qui sont les plus
vocal on va dire sur le problème que je
viens d'évoquer
mais dans un certain nombre de domaines
c'est aussi les plus gros consommateurs
compulsifs
c'est les jeunes sur consoles de l'avion
par exemple par rapport aux autres
classes d'âge dans l'électronique
c'est aussi des consommateurs j'ai envie
de dire proportionnellement très
important or l'empreinte carbone du
numérique est à nous elle est loin
d'être négligeable
l'empreinte carbone du système numérique
mondiale ces quatre pour cent des
émissions c'est la même chose que la
fois que mondial de camions
c'est une chose que les aciéries
mondiale commence à faire pas mal
alors de deux conseils le premier c'est
que pour avoir des perspectives pour
l'avenir
il ya à la fois la question de
l'activité professionnelle qui est très
importante c'est à dire comment est ce
que j'arrive à varier mon activité
professionnelle avait quelque chose qui
fait sens pour résoudre ce problème
alors du coup je vais pour une fois pas
faire de la pub pour moi mais faire de
la pub pour ariane justement o'shea
project on a créé un site qui s'appelle
chiffres jobs alors qu'on les moments
c'est très orienté emplois de cadres
dans mes rêves les plus fous j'aimerais
qu'on arrive à faire ça pour les autres
mais ça commence à donner des
indications pour où est ce qu'on peut
faire des choses qui sont un peu raccord
avec le problème à traiter
et puis il ya une deuxième chose qui est
importante c'est pas rester seul c'est
toujours beaucoup plus simple de faire
face à un problème qui est qui vous
secoue un peu quand on est inséré dans
une communauté et que cette communauté
partage la même préoccupation
donc c'est alors là je vais refaire un
peu de public et pour tous au sein au
sein du chis project enfin ou à côté du
lit project il ya eu une association de
personnes s'appelait shifters on trouve
pas mal de gens qui sont justement ça ne
se posait la tête et se poser des
questions c'est que quand on a un
problème
agir face aux problèmes en optimist
toujours une réaction une question une
dernière en tout cas avant qu'on ait les
ateliers ensuite eric ou d'un oui ce que
j'aime c'est qu'en fait on est sur un
problème existentiel
on est en train de parler de l'avenir et
même de la survie de l'humanité est pas
que l'humanité d'ailleurs de beaucoup
aussi du monde du vivant autour de nous
et donc évidemment que c'est anxiogène
que ça peut aussi donner envie à
beaucoup de gens de regarder de tourner
la tête de fermer les écoutilles
et donc on va voir de plus en plus je
pense des gens nostalgiques du passé qui
ont comme ça une vision très idéalisée
du passé qui vous montrer dans des
conservatismes et voire même dans des
radicalismes parce que ça va souvent
enfin voila c'est aussi des pentes donc
il ya toutes ces choses là qui sont un
petit peu au tournant mais moi il ya une
image qui m'a vraiment frappé que je
trouve très très bien vu de la part de
jean marc jancovici
c'est cette image de l'ironman parce
qu'en fait finalement qu'est ce qu'on
est en train de voir avec cette image
c'est à quel point nous sommes
aujourd'hui en train de payer la note
d'un délire de toute puissance
en fait nous sommes des êtres fragiles
de même que tout ce qui nous entoure
cette planète ces ressources cette bio
div
si t es là elle donne la sensation d'une
grande puissance mais en fait ce sont d
équilibre très fragile et je pense à
thomas pesquet qui en ce moment dans les
airs vous souvenez que la première fois
qu'il est parti dans la station spatiale
et qu'on lui a posé la question en lui
qui voyait donc la terre vue de l'espace
on lui a demandé de dire un adjectif il
a dit fragile et c'est vraiment ça c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui je pense qu'on
commence à prendre conscience de notre
délire de toute puissance et il va donc
falloir réaliser que derrière cette
armure d'iron man et ben il ya quand
même un petit bonhomme petite bonne
femme qui sont très fragiles et va
falloir donc se départir de ses divers
masques de ces couches qui sont soit
disant protectrice et dans lesquels on
est en train d'étouffer de s'atrophier
et de crever tout simplement
et donc c'est là où je vois l'espoir moi
parce que je pense véritablement que le
véritable aiment pas vraiment' dont on
parle beaucoup et ce phénomène aussi de
résilience et que sa terrasse et un peu
aujourd'hui des injonctions à la
résilience et bien et c'est surtout
savoir se se réconcilier avec cette
fragilité intrinsèque à notre condition
humaine et dans cette fragilité il y as
sans doute la source de tous les
bonheurs possibles parce
qu'effectivement ralentir le rythme et
et pouvoir voilà prendre le moment
extraordinaire de s'allonger dans
l'herbe regarder le ciel et c'est ce
qu'on arrive quasiment plus à faire
parce que nous avons des vies de fou et
bien c'est là où se trouve véritablement
nos bonheurs et donc c'est pas dans
cette croissance exponentielle sans fin
et c'est ça met dedans et si on
s'arrêtait un peu parce qu est ce qu on
a besoin de tout ça et où est ce que
sont vraiment les moments quand on est
sur notre lit de mort à quoi on pense la
nostalgie de tout petits moments qui en
souffrent donc pas coûté grand chose en
termes d'argent sonnant et trébuchant
et donc il est peut-être temps aussi de
changer nos indicateurs de richesse et
donc effectivement de mettre dans ces
indicateurs de richesse bien plus de
diversité que ce qui fait le pib etc
merci est vrai que une dernière question
vitesse rapide
jean-marc c'est que vous leur parlez à
plusieurs reprises pour être très clair
aujourd'hui nous cjd on s'investit pour
l'environnement on va essayer d'aller
plus loin
on est en train de mettre en place des
outils pour à aider nos adhérents a
développé le bilan carbone au sein de
leur entreprise ne serait ce que pour
prendre conscience
il ya beaucoup d'hétérogénéité dans la
caractéristique de nos adhérents et le
bilan carbone d'un avocat n'est pas le
même que celui d'une industrie chimique
et donc c'est tout le travail qu'on est
en train de mener aujourd'hui mais la
question je vais vous poser c'est que
vous avez fait un appel du pied à
plusieurs reprises ses co chief projets
que vous êtes clairement aujourd'hui en
train de rechercher des dons des
financements est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire plus aujourd'hui si je suis
dirigeant et je veux aider le chiffre
projet comment je fais alors oui
absolument on a lancé un appel
alors on l'a lancée avec une
arrière-pensée intéressés et une
beaucoup moins cher
l'histoire du plan de transformation de
l'économie française démarre il ya un
peu plus d'un an au moment du
confinement liés aux la première vague
du co lead à ce moment là on se dit
c'est un film qui est une grande claque
à l'économie mais c'est en même temps
une chance parce que il faut absolument
qu'on profite de cette opportunité pour
que quand l'économie repartira on essaie
de la faire repartir sur des bases
différentes
donc on s'est mis au travail pour voir
ce que pouvait signifier de mettre
l'économie sur des rails différents
correspondants des choses qu'on sait
raconter ici et là la réaction fait
d'elle le chemin faisant on a commencé
évidemment à parler de cette initiative
à droite et à gauche et on a eu un
certain nombre de retours qui étaient
des recours à la fin des retours pendant
leur foi d'encouragement et des retours
nous invitant à faire mieux et en
particulier on s'est rendu compte que ça
suscite de l'espoir ça nous oblige
vraiment à part à connaître et à être
vraiment très passive avoir fouillé
complet sérieux aura un peu de tout ça à
la fois dans notre travail et on s'est
rendu compte que
coup il fallait absolument qu'on
réhausse nos ambitions et car ce moment
on avait besoin de moyens
supplémentaires n'est besoin de mettre
des gens supplémentaire au travail de
travailler de manière plus approfondie
de couvrir plus de sujets etc et donc
que ça ça demande un peu plus d'argent
et comme le chi project reste une petite
entité on ne rien vous cacher on est une
association qui apporte deux millions de
budget par an ce n'est pas ridicule dans
le secteur mais ce qui reste quand même
très peu surtout si on veut sauver le
pays entre guillemets il par ailleurs on
s'est dit une deuxième chose on s'est
dit on va proposer de modifier dans
l'économie c'est absolument
indispensable qu'on ait un certain
nombre d'acteurs de l'économie de votre
foi évidemment c'est à dire partageant
avec nous l'intérêt de bien vous le de
vouloir faire des choses dans cette
direction qui nous qui nous qui nous
khaleej qui nous disent voilà ce que
vous avez pensé ok pour l'objectif mais
en pratique vous n'allez pas penser à
saucisse taulard ce qui veut dire que
votre truc risque de pas marché il vaut
peut-être mieux s'y prendre de cette
manière etc ou qui est ce que vous avez
pensé ce qu'on peut voir ce que vous
allez répondre quand on va vous objecter
tel truc et donc ça veut dire qu'on a
besoin de deux types de contributions
aujourd'hui en prenant des entreprises
on a besoin d'un dialogue et si possible
un dialogue partenariale donc d'où ce
qui nous intéresse c'est nouer des
partenariats avec des structures
existantes pour qu'elle même puissent
prendre en charge la logistique du
dialogue parce qu'un dialogue cette
demande de la logistique sa demande
d'organiser des réunions des
confrontations des machins etc
et donc on est à la recherche à la fois
d'argent pour faire mieux donc on va
garder pendant pour les restaurants
surtout ils vont et on a besoin
d'interlocuteurs de bonne volonté qui
nous aident à faire mieux sur le fond en
se mettant à leur place et parlent à
d'autres et en nous disant ce qu'ils
pensent des mesures que on est en train
de proposer et jusqu'où aussi d'en faire
une critique intelligente et on est
particulièrement désireux d'avoir des
entreprises dans ce cercle parce que si
on parle d'économie on parle
d'entreprises
c'est là que se passe pour une bonne
partie l'innovation c'est là que se
passe pour une bonne partie la création
d'emplois et donc hors ces deux points
qui sont absolument essentiels quand on
veut changer les choses
donc le voilà c'est un appel qui n'est
pas juste un appel j'ai envie de dire
financièrement intéressé en disant c'est
pas du fire and forget est un tas d nous
l'argent et ensuite on a plus envie
d'entendre parler de vous c'est vraiment
si vous croyez que ce qu'on fait est
utile parce qu'on n'aura pas 25 élection
présidentielle d'ici à 2050 et on en
reparle de ce qui c'est pour corriger le
problème donc j'ai dont je viens de
parler à ce moment votre soutien on
aimerait la voir à la fois sous forme
financière et sous forme d'un peu de
temps et enfin le dernier point son
soutien financier renvoie une des
questions qui étaient posées tout à
l'heure si on est capable de se compter
en grand nombre on sera écouté pendant
la campagne présidentielle c'est aussi
bête que ça jean marc jancovici pour les
échanges et puis aussi pour votre ton de
ferrante son nom est mêlé mais oui moi
notre plan d ici sur le plateau est
gouverné depuis peu plus mais
malheureusement le temps passe et c'est
la parole aux entrepreneurs mais dans
quelques instants parce qu'il va y avoir
les ateliers merci et et méconnue on se
retrouve tout à l'heure pour table ronde
de vous suivre vous la marraine donc que
de riglos ariane on passe à l'action
et bien tout à fait maintenant que le
problème est bel et bien posé merci
encore jean-marc il est temps de passer
à l'action comment agir dans son
entreprise pour le climat nous vous
proposons vous accompagner dans vos
premiers pas au travers de six ateliers
sectoriels
qui se dérouleront en parallèle restez
connecté vous allez pouvoir rejoindre
l'atelier de votre choix en fonction de
votre secteur d'activité en cliquant sur
une des options qui vous seront proposés
alors c'est parti pour les ateliers on
se retourne à 17 h 30 précisément ici en
direct direct pendant du parc du
futuroscope pour la suite du programme à
tout est là